hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer questions from
one of our readers robber who asked me
how you haven't loved your stuff I
watched listened very often question to
you how and where do I find salespeople
to sell web ads on my site help Robert
so Robert this is an area know a little
bit about since I have a similar
business worms I'm selling ad space
online for a while I was running my own
ad space and also using different ad
networks and settled on google adsense
and I would encourage people to you know
buy the ad space that i have in unmarked
cars from what I would sell my nonsense
adds to but then I eventually switched
over to now or it's only Adsense and
there's a couple reason why I do it
first of all Google doesn't take that
big a commission off the sales that
makes to your site so it's thirty two
percent for any publisher they keep
thirty percent you keep sixty-eight
percent which is a pretty good
Commission you're still making a lot on
the back end I found that Google doesn't
much better job at finding appetizers
for each specific page so you get
targeted ads which increases the chance
of people will click on those ads and
that's how you end up getting paid and
the best part is is no hassle right
there's no customers to deal with and
reports to have to give it's all
automatic Google takes care of all of
that so I've automated the entire
process on my business and you can
optimize the odds to try to make more
money
come in every month but I found that
would be the best solution for me if
you're really sold on selling your own
ad space the first thing I would do is
make sure you have a page that is
clearly explains all the different
databases you have in the benefits that
people can get if you're sold on having
to go find somebody when I hired people
to pass the best fly found people who
are known so maybe not friends but
associates people I've met who I a good
kind of working relationship with from
meeting them and thought maybe there's
an opportunity to be able to work
together as always come from my own
network I haven't had too much luck in
terms of placing ads craigslist or a job
or two chatted people to come in some of
my entrepreneur friends have had success
by using recruiters who specifically
focus on finding salespeople you know
depending on what market you want you
want to find somebody who's close to you
and help with that again I found the
best solution to go no sales people and
do everything through events but if
you're you know soul again and that
sales person if I'm in first out start
with your media network look at contacts
you have friends of friends people
you've met if we've respected and see if
there might be an opportunity to work
even at a part-time basis to get started
and if that's it as the work you might
want to consider looking for a recruiter
who might be able to help you get that
says person before so I hope that helps
if you like the video please give it a
thumbs up below I'd also love to hear
your thoughts and feedback if you want
to leave a comment below this video and
stay tuned to the next episode
you